l'enquète sur l'assassinât du petit
grégory dans les vosges cette enquête
continue et il est bien difficile de
savoir qui est l'auteur de ce crime
abominable
nous allons maintenant faire le point de
cette enquête difficile et notamment
avec l'interview de l'avocat de la
partie civile la famille les parents du
petit grégory
grégory un nom et un visage que tout le
monde connaît mais aujourd'hui treize
jours après sa mort
treize jours après qu'on ait retrouvé
son corps ligoté et noyé dans cette
rivière
on ne sait toujours pas qui l'a tué ni
même pourquoi
bien sûr il ya ce fameux corbeau
l'auteur des lettres et des appels
téléphoniques anonymes qui menaçaient
les parents de grégory et ont revendiqué
le crime mais pourquoi on a parlé d'une
affaire familiale de rivalité une piste
qui semble aujourd'hui abandonné les
parents de grégory d'une famille plus
modeste qu'on l'a d'abord dit et qui ne
comprend pas les raisons du drame qui la
frappe est pas impossible et que
l'assassin ou les assassins s'ils sont
plusieurs soit animé par la haine mais
j'avais ont peut-être hays sans savoir
par qui et je ne pense qu'on ne peut pas
dire que ce qu'ils ont connu une
réussite sociale
ils ont connu une réussite due au
travail
la mère travaille comme ouvrière dans
une filature le père travaille aussi
dans une filature nous sommes dans les
vosges comme contre m ce ne sont
absolument pas des gens riches ce sont
les travailleurs il faut tout d'indiquer
il faut le trouver parce que si on
trouve pas cette à ça il va se créer une
psychose de peur terrible
les gendarmes ont entendu plus de 80
personnes
plusieurs suspects ont été retenus puis
relâché fausse piste
deux portraits robots différentes été
diffusée mais le ou les assassins
courent toujours et le temps joue pour
eux